(waltz music)
(audience clapping)
The Germans are famously
comfortable with nudity.
They don't think it's a
big deal and they love
nude beaches.
I was very surprised to
find that just outside
downtown Berlin, near a
canal, there is a nude beach.
I wanted to explore it
so I took along my guide
Flula.
Hello, how are you?
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm doing very well.
When I called you and
said, would you join me?
I didn't even say I was
going to a nude beach.
Yeah, I know.
(male in audience laughs)
Are you naked a lot?
'Cause the Germans are very
comfortable with nudity.
We don't enjoy clothing.
Like if it is not required,
like at a library,
or perhaps a supermarket, booties are out,
cleavages, let those fly
around like free birds.
(audience laughs)
Okay, this is the first time
I've been to a nude beach.
Yes.
How do you feel?
It's a little strange I have to say.
You look around and a lot of
men walking, and they have
their, what do the Germans call it?
Penis.
(audience laughs)
Is that what, did you mean that?
Always good to learn a new language.
(man in audience laughs)
I mean, look, you turn right
there and there's a man's ass,
we're looking right into that man's
ass and it's, you know, like.
Have you not seen a
man's anus before, I mean?
I have seen it yes.
There's another one.
Okay.
(audience laughs and claps)
I love what you're wearing.
You're always wearing
the sneakers are great.
Thank you.
Yeah, to protect.
To protect, and you have
your trusty little fanny pack.
Yeah.
What do you have,
what do you keep in there?
I have a snack for you Conan.
You have a snack?
(audience laughs)
I have some schnitzel's.
Schnitzel's, what are they?
Schnitzel.
What is it?
It's gluten free.
(schnitzel's crunching)
You just bite it.
Mm hmm.
Mmm!
I went to the nude beach,
met a man, and bit into his schnitzel.
Is that what you say?
(audience laughs)
Yeah, because we just did that.
Mine had two meanings.
(audience clapping)
What was it, what do you mean?
Well it could also be like the penis.
You know the schnitzel.
This is, no, penis is not gluten free.
(audience laughs)
The guy back there, he
looks a lot like Sting.
Perhaps it is Sting, Sting loves Berlin!
He loves Berlin and he
probably comes here all the time.
Yeah, yes!
Sending an SOS and the
massages in the bottles.
Message.
Hm?
Nothing.
Hello, how are you?
Good and you?
I'm good, what is your name?
Tobias.
Tobias would you like a snack?
Would you like a little,
Yes, of course.
yeah, schnitzel.
There you go.
Schnitzel.
[Flula] Schnitzel.
Oh, thank you very much.
[Flula] Yeah.
This is normal, very
natural in Germany right?
This is not normal for me.
I'm not happy when I'm nude.
You're born without clothes though.
Yes, actually I was born with clothes.
(audience laughs)
Convinced I was.